hello reject nation
I'm Greg Alba Brianne Chandler is here
from Miss movies YouTube channel
she was actually just on movie fights
was it last week two weeks ago two weeks
ago I wish it was two weeks ago yeah
that sounds about right
tune in to see how she did she did
terribly yeah terribly is what I would
use here in the Schmo down you can see
me I did the post interview match
between NIC Scarpino and josh mokuba
okay she's the undercard of William
Viviani and Drew McWeeny
just last Friday you're gonna be on
you're gonna be attending our Collider
live show though right I will be at the
live March 15th people
she'll be there I'll be there I have to
contractually all I need is yeah did you
sign a contract I did I don't do
anything without contract okay well
that's right because it's full screen
yeah so you definitely said yeah yeah
all right well we're gonna watch today
from one of my favorite YouTube channels
they do these great list videos channel
called what culture I've never heard of
well you're gonna hear from them today
7 biggest movie set note downs Christian
Bale is gonna be alright no Lily Tomlin
is what I was Lily Tomlin - yeah yeah
what you off the [ __ ] set you prick D
monetization all the right where the
pressure has got too much for one of the
actors for directors involved and some
other poor soul from the cast or crew
usually feels their rent
as a result additionally these outbursts
here's our examines of news and words or
wound up on the internet and in some
cases they're more entertaining area
itself I'm Calvin what culture coma this
is the seventh biggest movie Sentinel
Dario answer back we're number seven
Russell Russell and well-liked believe
on the center 500 I've seen the footage
of that
this is a friendly exchange that started
out as a run-of-the-mill disagreement
when Tommy complains have been given too
much direction but later escalates into
an all and firestorm needless the same
Russell doesn't come up particularly
well dying six Morenstein
Reservoir don't really think you need 20
more feature-length debut and that's
probably a nice way to describe Ron's
tyranny during the filming of Quentin
Tarantino's Reservoir other way he never
came back to was a toxic influence
throughout from scuffling with Michael
Madsen to poaching his lines in almost
every scene timmy was every filmmakers
worse
exploded into a shooting of the most
fantastic recreated this awesome
we had students sobbing uncontrollably
and thrashed around shattering the
mirror and cutting his tongue on a
broken shot understandably
the Queen was freaked out and ready to
abandon the shoot but she urged them to
keep the cameras rolling
number three Lucy Liu the role is
rumored to have been recast for the
sequel because there was a serious
verbal warfare between the Ghostbusters
actor and his co-star Lucy Liu on the
set to happen at one point is she told
me mo he is said to have appraised his
angels remarking on Cameron Diaz and
Drew Barrymore's acting skills but when
he came to Liu he simply said what the
hell are you doing here you can't she's
also really to have launched a physical
attack on him and had to be restrained
by members of the crew he was just all
about the incident on apparently
[Laughter]
push an x-ray Russell was generally
being rustled throughout the shoot which
on this occasion meant having bourbon be
dense the cameramen script supervisors
and experts the situation came to a head
what attended extra was reluctant to
help clinging to the ground in an action
scene prompting the irate
director to act the cement of him this
is when clearly stepped in and fix the
Russell's death only retaliated when the
filmmaker grows him by the throat a
balloon scrap ensued and that was the
final straw the second assistant
director Paul Bern oh I don't know about
that on the spot well I work with David
ever again do I think he's tremendously
talented and do I think you should be
nominated for Oscars yeah all the way
thanks what culture okay let's break a
couple of these down okay David
O'Russell just there's more than just
these two with David O'Russell like Dave
David Russell has a terrible reputation
you know there was one writer director I
don't want to say his name I've actually
talked to him to her but he actually has
a TV show right now he was telling how
when he you start making a big break him
and David O'Russell almost got into a
fistfight during a press conference and
you can actually find this footage
because theater Russell was just being a
dick to him and it surprises me that
some people still will work with him
consistently like I haven't heard
anything terrible about the guy in a few
years around like the you know the
fighter and silver linings playbook I
mean he seems like he's kind of chilled
out a little bit cuz Jennifer Lawrence
keeps working with him might help the
guy out but that footage you can find
that I mean you've seen it right there's
like multiple it's not just one scene in
the car yeah verbally abusive it is so
crazy it surprised me that Mark Wahlberg
actually knowing Mark Wahlberg knowing
what I know of Mark Wahlberg especially
in recent events it doesn't fully
surprise me that he would still work
with David or Russell because two out of
the three movies for David
has developed a reputation for being a
hothead Mark Wahlberg and both of those
but it just keeps returning to work with
the guy here that boy has a temper too
actually
yes a and they understand each other I
understand that sometimes you've got you
just gotta call someone to C word in the
F word I don't know get it man
it did surprise me to hear about the
Reservoir Dogs one I never knew about
that Lawrence Tierney I think what
surprised me about it is Reservoir Dogs
is you know his big debut film and most
of the characters in there have had a
chance to return in an upcoming or
follow up Tarantino film and Lawrence
Tierney being the head of the mob I
thought he gave a great performance in
the film so I thought like he would be
one of those actors a Tarantino would
eventually bring back but this makes
sense nowadays no one would do that
would like this is young Tarantino
directorial debut if people are gonna
push him around he might actually take
it a little bit but nowadays oh man
Tarantino I was right he's not on this
list because I don't know if he's had
like onset freak outs he there's footage
of him freaking out on people on you to
see at least three videos I can think of
one with a news anchor one where he's at
Sundance and the camera comes up there
he's fit said someone on the Oscars oh
that famous interview with that one dude
no it's mine it's my job to try and ask
you to and I'm shutting your butt down
I'm not saying he has a wild ass time
for that dude but I imagine when you're
like young and you're trying to make it
happen that you probably let yourself
get knocked around a little bit more The
Terminator Salvation one easily my
favorite I've downloaded an audio johner
and I will still it was everywhere man
everyone was quoting it at the time you
just couldn't because it was kind of
funny in a weird way I think it's funny
because you just know how ridiculous you
sound
yeah I have it on my laptop I will still
play it it should be your road out
entrance I think that should be a road
out entrance are losing our [ __ ] on
Christian
Martin Sheen on Apocalypse Now they call
this meltdown right so you always
assumed like oh it's about them like
losing their temper or whatever you know
every once in a while you get a great
improvised moment that's real and it
works for film and that's like one of
the classic scenes in the movie right
there it happens on screen you watch it
yeah and it's crazy to learn that after
you watch it cuz I think parts of
darkness the documentary about making
Apocalypse Now no I haven't I heard it's
a [ __ ] to make it is it was like a
nightmare of a movie oh yeah like almost
did Francis Ford Coppola how does he say
it
Coppola Coppola Coppola I'm just
considered one of Hollywood's best
movies by most people lost Best Director
to Bob Fosse that year for cabaret Wow I
hope that's a question during our live
match Thursday March 15th at the El
Portal Theatre Collider showdown
attendant get tickets now 8:00 p.m. a
p.m. I'll be there I'll be there Bill
Murray and Lucy Liu is something my mom
told me about because she loves People
magazine she still does not read
celebrity news - yeah shoot my mama wake
up every morning blow-dry her hair while
reading People magazine and she's the
one who told me about Lucy Liu and Bill
Murray not getting along
do you think that was a joke he was
making you know I don't know the context
so she took it pretty seriously which
maybe it wasn't a joke that he was
making yeah sure looking at it outside
not knowing any of the situations it
sounds and knowing him sounds like it
could be it could have been a real joke
but also I don't know yeah because when
I see Charlie angels I'm like Lucy Liu's
acting levels on par with everyone else
yeah I don't really know why Bill Murray
would take a stab at her or something
it sounds like he had a crush on her and
he was taking out his lust by putting
her down allegedly that's how that some
men are
why because we don't understand our
emotions we're at the garden yourself
crying is weak only anger Jerry
O'Connell I had no idea this happen dude
Oh snow golfing got high nowadays that's
like that's not exactly unheard of
people who could get high onset but for
a young and yeah sort of hippie fare
they said they had to halt shooting yeah
because he was like he was like stone
was he not like a where he was gonna get
high or did he just like show just like
like a cookie or a brownie or something
not knowing it was in there I would have
loved to have been on the Sephiroth last
meltdown I remember was Britney Spears
in the umbrella and the shaved head that
was the last meltdown you can remember I
mean I'm not personally involved you not
go on y'all the one thing I'll add okay
you know I Christian Bale I think is the
perfect example a lot of people have
heard that audio and immediately go
Christian Bale is just nothing but an
[ __ ] now like people will immediately
assume he's just a bad person for what
happened and even the DP has come out
and said like there was someone just
bound loser there your [ __ ] on set one
day and Christian was just the one who
happened to do it he apologized right
away and all those things but no one
really cares about that
the reason why I think acting is such a
fascinating endeavor for someone to take
on is because Christian will play
characters like an American Psycho a
pissed-off Batman like losing his cool
people be like great when he does it
with a real life when he has a freakout
moment a human moment everyone's like
what a terrible person
all right guys well you can subscribe to
walk culture or subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell to
get notified every time one of our bids
is up could subscribe buttons undo
anything and miss movies you can catch
her on YouTube every ones that you do a
live show right I do 6 degrees 30 tune
in people I've been on it Jon's been on
it I've been on the film therapy
a couple times make sure to check her
out porfavor and on Instagram and the
Twitter's as well that's right and we
have a patreon yeah there you go that's
the last plug see you guys